now to the war in ukraine where a
russian supply base deep in territory
controlled by moscow just became a
target
fires and explosions continued overnight
in crimea the region that russia seized
from ukraine back in 2014.
ukraine has not claimed responsibility
but its president is praising civilians
for giving information to its
intelligence services charlie daggett is
nearby in southern ukraine he's
following the priest fighting there
charlie good morning to you
good morning gail russia calls the
explosions in crimea sabotage sources
here will only hint that elite covert
teams may be responsible whatever the
cause the back-to-back attacks signal a
dramatic new phase of the war in this
region
the electricity substation up in flames
exploding ammunition at a weapons depot
orchestrated attacks following last
week's assault on an air base creating
chaos in russian-controlled crimea
appears to be part of the strategy in
ukraine's push to retake neighboring
curson where we visited villages
liberated by ukrainian troops but still
under fire dinas kokorodko community
leader of zagradivka told us residents
have just fractions of a second to react
to this showing
sometimes you don't even have time to
reach a safe place she said if you're in
the garden you fall to the ground in the
garden
we're standing in a province that is
largely under russian occupation and
schools like this and villages like
these are under constant bombardment and
now they're preparing for the
counter-attack likely to be launched
from this region vladimir pashock
returned with his young family after
fleeing under gunfire when russian
troops overran this village are you
prepared for what may happen in the
weeks and
i know that the intensity of warfare is
going to rise he said i'm sick and tired
of it
sadly six-year-old daughter nastia has
more combat experience than most
soldiers when your daughter gets
frightened what do you tell her
she knows when the ukrainian army is
shooting says mother alyona but when she
hears incoming shots she hides in the
house she tells me i hear a howitzer or
that was a tank shot she knows
everything
the father told us he came back before
his family to make sure the house was
safe only to find out that russian
soldiers had been using it to store
weapons they set booby traps in the
kitchen and the bedroom that explosive
teams had to defuse and clear out
nate
kids should not know the type of
artillery by the sound of it that's for
sure charlie dagda in southern ukraine
thank you